Leo a young boy suffers a tragic
accident during his childhood rendering
him unable to speak his devout Amish
mother deeply rooted in her faith
adamantly refuses to allow Leo to
undergo surgery to restore his voice
fast forward to the year 2035 when Leo
has grown into an adult and now works as
a bartender at a bustling strip club in
the vibrant city of Berlin the club is
owned by a man named Maxim who also
happens to be Leo's boss Leo is in a
relationship with Nadira a Charming
cocktail waitress at the club however
Nadira carries a heavy secret she
confides in her friend Luba expressing
her reluctance to disclose her troubled
past and desperate financial situation
to Leo the weight of her Secrets weighs
heavily on her mind one night a Rowdy
customer named Stewart begins to
sexually harass Nadira crossing the line
of decency Leo witnessing the ordeal is
filled with a surge of protectiveness
towards Nadira and takes matters into
his own hands he confronts Stuart and
resorts to physical violence Nadira
understanding the precariousness of her
job pleads with Leo to Let It Go
emphasizing the importance of
maintaining her employment pivotal
moment arises when Nadira unexpectedly
shows up at Leo's apartment her eyes
filled with a sense of urgency she
attempts to convey something of great
significance to Leo however before she
can find the words Leo surprises her
with a breathtaking gesture of love he
presents her with an exquisitely carved
bed a labor of love that he has been
meticulously crafting as a gift for her
overwhelmed by the depth of his
affection Nadira succumbs to her
emotions and they share a passionate and
intimate moment together meanwhile in
another part of the city Maxim's
criminal Associates encounter two
American surgeons named Cactus Bill and
duck desperate to leave Berlin Bill
implores Maxime to provide him and his
young daughter Josie with forged
documents bill is consumed by the desire
to escape his current life on the other
hand duck Revels in the Berlin lifestyle
and runs a clandestine business offering
cybernetic implants and Performing
underground surgeries the escalating
tension takes a toll on Leo's life when
Stewart resurfaces at the strip club
instigating a confrontation their
altercation catches the attention of
Maxime leading him to terminate Leo's
employment as Leo finds himself unable
to contact adira he turns to Luba
seeking her assistance however Luba in
an unexpected turn of events refuses to
offer any help or support just when all
seems lost Leo receives an anonymous
text message that leads him to a covert
Black Market Bazaar which Stewart
happens to oversee at the bazaar Leo
stumbles upon Bill and Josie discovering
their presence amidst the commotion
sensing an opportunity bill seizes the
moment to whisk Josie away as Stewart
confronts Leo a sudden Revelation
strikes Leo's memory he recalls Nadira
discreetly writing an address on his
notepad some time ago determined to find
her Leo hastily departs from the chaotic
Bazaar resorting to using charcoal to
decipher the faint imprint left on his
notepad following nadira's address Leo
embarks on a quest that leads him to
Oswald intrigued by a picture of Nadira
Leo expresses his interest unwittingly
leading Oswald to assume that Leo works
for Nikki simsek one of Maxim's henchmen
unbeknownst to Maxime Nikki has been
pocketing money from the earnings of his
prostitutes Leo arranges a meeting with
simsek who is unexpectedly babysitting
Josie Bill's daughter as fate would have
it Leo strikes up a bond with Josie
finding solace in her innocent presence
utilizing this opportunity Leo
discreetly places the money from Oswald
in a carefully crafted note
incriminating simsek right in front of
Maxim's watchful enforcers determined to
uncover nadira's whereabouts Leo follows
the trail to her supposed address only
to discover Luba awaiting him instead
Luba confesses that both he and Nadira
have resorted to working as prostitutes
to secure the desperately needed funds
fueled by jealousy Lube events his anger
at nadira's affection for Leo rather
than himself this Revelation shakes Leo
to his core casting a shadow over his
journey driven by a need for answers Leo
perseveres and manages to track down
nadira's mother in a heart-wrenching
revelation Leo learns that Nadira is
Josie's mother and it becomes clear that
bill is responsible for nadira's sudden
disappearance the pieces of the puzzle
begin to fall into place bringing forth
a surge of determination within Leo
meanwhile Maxime orders Bill and duck to
extract information from simsek through
merciless torture in a shocking turn of
events Bill stumbles upon explicit
images of children on Duck's computer
Awakening a wave of Fury within him
threatening to to break Duck's arms
should he ever lay a finger on a child
Bill's mood takes a drastic shift when
Maxime announces that the forged
documents are ready Paving the way for
their escape from Berlin Overjoyed by
the prospect of Freedom Bill takes duck
out for a night of revelry extending his
Hospitality by offering his own house to
duck in a moment of casual conversation
duck carelessly reveals that he was the
anonymous texter who had been
communicating with Leo using it as an
outlet to vent his frustrations with
Bill however their Jubilation is
short-lived as they encounter a security
guard who suspects them of theft when
the situation escalates Bill threatens
the guard's life but duck intervenes
attempting to defuse the tension in a
fit of rage Bill strikes duck further
fracturing their already strained
partnership disheartened by Bill's
callous Behavior duck secretly sends Leo
a text revealing Bill's location
empowered by a newfound resolve Leo
harnesses the support beam from the bed
he so meticulously crafted armed with
this makeshift weapon he confronts Maxim
and his henchmen unleashing a wave of
Retribution upon them Leo emerges
Victorious seizing the opportunity to
claim the hard-earned forged documents
that will ultimately alter his Destiny
armed with these documents Bill moves
forward on his quest to find Nadira
however what he finds is something far
more horrifying than what he had
expected inside Bill's house Leo is
confronted with a grisly scene he
discovers a severely injured simsek and
to his horror nadira's lifeless body
concealed in a bag she had been
mercilessly murdered by Bill consumed by
rage and grief Leo exacts his revenge
swiftly dispatching simsik however Bill
refuses to relent he launches a
ferocious attack on Leo seeking to
eliminate the one who has crossed his
path but fate takes an unexpected turn
in a desperate struggle Leo manages to
impale bill on his own knife putting an
end to Bill's reign of violence amidst
this chaos duck arrives at the scene
instead of offering Aid or calling for
medical assistance he callously
disregards Bill's critical condition
taking advantage of the situation duck
positions the surveillance camera
installed in Josie's room directing its
focus on Bill's face with cruel
intention he taunts Bill hinting at the
Unspeakable acts he plans to subject
Josie to in the future while Leo remains
unconscious duck season is the
opportunity to assert his dominance
further he implants an electro larynx
into Leo's throat granting him the
ability to hear Leo apologize for the
killing of Bill however Leo refuses to
succumb to Duck's demands steadfastly
rejecting any notion of Remorse
undeterred by Leo's Defiance duck takes
him to the very Bridge captured in the
soul photograph Leo possesses of Nadira
standing at the precipice Leo remains
Resolute refusing to offer the apology
duck seeks summoning courage Leo takes a
deep breath and with a forceful act
plunges both himself and duck into the
cold depths of the water below as the
waters close in around them duck meets
his demise succumbing to the unforgiving
currents in a Moment of clarity Leo
manages to shout a warning to Josie
cautioning her against approaching the
treacherous edge of the bridge with
their lives spared Leo ensures Josie's
safety promising to take her to her
maternal grandmother a sanctuary where
she will find Solace and protection time
passes wounds heal and Leo finds himself
seated in a peaceful restaurant
alongside Josie the scars of their
harrowing experiences gradually fade
replaced by Newfound hope and
Tranquility together they engage a quiet
activity drawing pictures that reflect
their shared journey and the bond they
have forged click on one of the videos
on your screen right now
[Music]